we're always trying to step up our game
to see if we can get the craziest camera
techniques possible and that's something
that i'm going to try to do today ready
to see it take off i'm like so excited
i've been wanting to do this for a while
all right now it's no secret that i'm a
big fan of 360 cameras we've made a lot
of videos about them if you haven't seen
them go check them out they allow you to
do all kinds of crazy camera moves like
this
or even this look at me i'm a big alien
i'm also a big fan of drones i love
flying them i love making videos with
them but something that i haven't done
yet is put a 360 camera on a racing
drone
now by putting a 360 camera on a racing
drone i'm hoping i'll be able to
discover some really sweet new camera
moves that can really step our game up
for our next anime film these are some
of my favorite videos we've made because
they combine just the most absurd
storytelling with just the craziest
camera moves we've used like gopro
gimbals to get really fast but smooth
motion and we're always trying to step
up our game to see if we can get the
craziest camera techniques possible but
before we proceed let me talk about what
racing drones even are now you're
probably familiar with something that
looks like this this is a classic dji
phantom and they're part of a whole
breed of drones that are meant for
smooth cinematography however the flight
characteristics of a cinema drone like
this is very limited they can't really
do all that much unlike a racing drone
like this which on top of being very
fast is also incredibly acrobatic you
can do barrel rolls and flips and get
all kinds of crazy cameras
it's a little like comparing a
commercial airliner to a fighter jet i'm
hoping this will allow us to get some
incredibly dynamic shots
now this is actually a video i've been
wanting to do for quite some time but
i've been very hesitant up until this
point because the one x is honestly like
pretty much my favorite camera and if i
crash there's a very real chance i'll
break it fortunately today insta360 has
agreed to sponsor this video so that if
i do crash and break the camera they'll
replace it for me
that takes out a lot of worry about
breaking my equipment makes me feel
better about doing crazier stuff so and
with your track record and what what
excuse me
he's sneezing it's about to seize oh god
back up he's back oh
bless you
all right so i was debating whether i
should put it on the
buzz or the new one and i've decided to
go with the new one because i want to
fly hd but here's the thing i have an
idea on how to mount it i just don't
know how well it's going to work a guy
named nerk who is a drone racing league
pilot actually came up with this idea
it's a classic gopro mount so this
quarter inch screw thread here will
actually mount perfectly with the 360
camera
so this is the idea it's got sticky
stuff on the bottom of the mount i'm
just gonna stick this to the drone and
then put some zip ties around us to
secure it in place hopefully that'll
work this is about the same weight as a
gopro hero 7. but here's the thing that
concerns me nick it's not so much the
weight of it as much as the weight
distribution you see this is a really
tall dude here yeah it brings the center
of gravity a little further up so it's
going to actually perform a little
differently than what i'm used to and i
put the battery on backwards dang it
so here is the camera put on it i'm
really excited dude i'm like so excited
i've been wanting to do this for a while
you gotta take this to the streets or
the park using the parks
all right
here's my transmitter this is how i
control the drone here are the goggles
this is how i see where the drone is
going i'm pretty much ready to fly let's
get this thing in the air
all right
okay let's get to safety
you ready to see it take off
[Music]
you're up
all right it's flying i don't felt any
difference in flight characteristics
just yet but i haven't pushed it very
hard yet i'm gonna do a flyby ready
[Music]
yeah it's definitely requiring more
thrust to stay in the air which makes
sense it's heavier
dude okay
yeah definitely it's got a big butt it's
got a big fat butt big jungus
oh all right that's the landing and that
was landing huh
not a bad flight
not a bad flight like that actually flew
surprisingly well okay for the next
battery i'm gonna try to do some flips
and rolls and power loops
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
i hit a tree you hit the tree
oh no it's just bent it just bent look
at that
that's straight down you cut this branch
off
why do i do those things nick
this prop is bent but the emax ones are
so durable i can literally bend it back
and keep flying
[Music]
ren came to me this morning with a big
smile on his face he said nick i've been
flying all weekend and i got some sweet
footage to show you
so this right here is the raw stitched
footage from the camera because you have
one video clip from one lens and another
video clip from the other lens and the
program automatically stitches this
stuff that used to be a huge process
back in the day i'm glad it's not a
process anymore but what we're seeing
here is what's called an equirectangular
image that's been flattened
i'm so proud of you guys you know like
when you're looking at a map of the
earth and greenland and canada look huge
that's because you take a globe
essentially slice it down the middle
unwrap it and flatten it okay so here's
the first flight remember the one that i
tried to go really really slow and
steady on i was expecting a lot more
vibrations but i didn't really get many
and the camera is able to stabilize out
pretty much most of the motion it flew
perfectly
this is the easiest effect to do with
the camera which is the tiny planet
effect think of like taking like the
most fish eye lens possible and then
pointing it straight down it can still
see all the different directions but
because of that it creates this weird
curved look so another aspect of this is
that you can actually choose your field
of view to be incredibly wide way wider
than a gopro this is closer to like a
typical gopro style look except it's
also stabilized there's not really any
picture roll motion and what strikes me
is cool about this is that you can
essentially take one shot and end up
with a whole variety of shots from that
one run
what the heck
that motion blur oh man that's so cool
my favorite part about doing this style
of camera move is the incredible sense
of speed it produces i did this on my
phone i literally transferred the
footage from the one x to my phone over
wi-fi processed it there and then
exported it to my phone it makes it
really easy and great for just uploading
directly to instagram or facebook it's
really nice speaking of which if you
follow the corridor digital instagram
it's right there you'll have already
seen a lot of this footage that's been
posted the link's below you right now
wes so another really cool aspect that
doing something like this allows me is
to choose my framing after the fact at
whatever orientation and zoom that i
want here i can turn on what's called
free capture and now i can actually like
look around so i was just flying along
and there's some cars driving up and
down this road and i i was careful not
to fly up next to the car however i
could still stare at the car no matter
where i flew
it looks it looks very cinematic when i
do it that way until the of course the
drone gets into the shot yeah there's a
huge amount of freedom there it makes me
just really want to go shoot a test i i
don't think it's worth doing a full-on
like narrative thing but more of like a
proof-of-concept narrative piece do you
think you could follow a frisbee in
there yeah i've never chased something
that's been thrown before so i don't
know if it's going to be really easy or
if it's going to be a challenge so when
doing a narrative cinematic thing you
don't want to see the drone at all even
if it does look cool so i had an idea i
found this in the in the closet
so this is i haven't tested this but i
think it'll be fine this was attached
down here but now it's up here how is it
going to balance dude hey man drones are
powerful by putting extra distance
between the lens of the camera and the
props of the drone itself it will now
appear much smaller in frame i'm really
hoping this works out we should go to
the park
[Music]
so unfortunately these are not the best
uh frisbees to actually play catch with
they're meant for frisbee golf
so far i was unimpressed with the throws
that i've been seeing how am i supposed
to track a long distance throw yeah i'm
gonna try throwing it as far as i can
you ready
[Applause]
so just to begin i i think we should
just do some shots where we literally
are just throwing the frisbee as far as
they can i will just try to do my best
to actually like track that so i'm gonna
get my little extension pole out this is
mighty ridiculous
that's is wrong man there's nothing
about this that isn't wrong
i only have four flights i say we do it
oh it looks a little wobbly it is a
little wobbly though
[Music]
go
[Music]
this is
gonna be a challenge
try to time the throw with my flyby you
ready
wait wait wait wait wait wait
i was definitely not ready coming by and
go
yeah so it turns out this is going to be
way harder than i expected
my battery's done i got to come in for
landing
[Music]
it was really
oh yeah very hard oh man it's just
really hard to guess where the frisbee
is going to go and how fast it's going
to get there and it's unpredictable with
the wind and everything what if we just
do a couple controlled shots maybe wes
and i time it to you imagine this is wes
right here it's imagine this is nick you
guys are here and you're throwing the
frisbee between you two i'm just gonna
be flying the drone just up and down
beside you guys here so i'll be like
go for it all right keep throwing but
try to throw it in sync with me uh going
by you here we go yes
yes
this is great oh my god they're having
their best catches yet
we're finally starting to sync up on how
it was actually uh flying by while
they're throwing and they were catching
it i think we got some sweet shots there
i felt like you got some great setup
moments and even some throws see back at
the studio
we have the footage and unfortunately we
ran into an issue that was my fault i
didn't properly calibrate the camera oh
no
what does that mean what does that mean
when you calibrate the camera you go
through the menu hit calibrate you put
it here then you hit calibrate and
that's how it knows where the horizon is
this is level when i calibrated it i did
it like this so that meant that all of
the footage was like 90 degrees sideways
and i couldn't change the horizon and
that meant that i couldn't use my phone
to actually do the free capture and the
desktop software wasn't able to help me
there either so is all the footage gone
can we use the footage
oh man this pause this pause is too long
for me man it's like okay
here's the thing it was some extra work
that i gave myself by doing this wrong
but we got some pretty sweet shots we
know the potential that this camera can
give you from a racing drum perspective
but for a narrative standpoint here
specifically check this out look at that
you
okay so yeah this could definitely cut
in can be like a good character intro oh
i like that
i like them a lot like a little charge
up shot see what's nice about this is
that not only can you look anywhere you
want i'm able to actually like zoom in
oh that's cool oh i really like that
that's awesome i feel like if we were
actually to make an anime frisbee short
we would just use the drone as the
camera and then add a cg frisbee you
know what honestly that's the way we
should have done it is just add a cg
frisbee the other definite problem i
found when doing this is that even
though the one x has like almost 6k
resolution to see the frisbee have to
crop in so tight we're looking at like a
240p version so the camera definitely
shines the wider your field of view is
so this system is like super cool for
getting those sweet establishing shots
my biggest takeaway is don't screw
yourself by uncalibrating your camera
but secondly we needed to play to the
strengths of this camera which is big
movements big objects and frame anime
frisbee wasn't really the right use case
for a camera like this we definitely
learned the limitations of this rig if
we want to incorporate this for some
specific shots in a narrative video we
now know that that's exactly what we
have to do and we can't just shoot the
whole dang thing on it so we're always
trying to like push the bounds of what
we can even try and do here and you know
what we're not going to stop we're going
to continue experimenting so make sure
you subscribe i did shoot a bunch of
other footage so if you want to see some
pretty sweet stuff
stay tuned right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you